it is the 26 year old two-way wonder
shohei ohtani
to make his 10th starting assignment of
the year most recently friday in the
desert
a five-inning start against the
diamondbacks in which he struck out
eight did not factor into the decision
of a
six to five angels victory grossman
stays put and it's a swing and a miss
probably a good thing they didn't send
him there scope strikes out
two long played appearances for rotani
one away so two runners aboard now for
the future hall of famer miguel cabrera
and a fastball just poured right past
he couldn't catch up three fastballs
strikeout
a guy that's known as one of the better
fastball hitters in baseball
here's the other part of the big story
tonight rod jay it's matt manning
making his major league debut tonight
exciting stuff
yes out of sacramento you know he has
his family his friends you know they're
all
from the state of california they're
they're going to be in attendance
upton chops it to third for candelario
manning comes back after falling behind
three and one to get his first out
jared walsh is a dead red fastball
hitter like that
right on the button but right at the doo
to retire the side
the angels are hoping to have anthony
brendon back
tomorrow first ball swinging is a keel
badou and that one's into right field
but do showing that flash he's around
second on his way to third
throw there is in time
i like the aggressive install boy this
from our angle here
i mean that was as bad as textbook as
you can do as far as getting to the
relay man
taylor ward a first round pick as a
catcher
throws that in the running heap of him
right on the money good tag by keith
wong
great on the back the throw gets him at
third base you can't play that any
better
as far as hitting your relay man
i just you know told him to go and enjoy
it and have fun you know you only get to
do this once you only debut once so
just enjoy it and have fun
wong with the base hit back up the
middle but he turns into two
you know breaking posture because it
opens up the rest of the plate you know
the last thing you want is
hitters you know the last thing you want
is hitters to be comfortable
through the hole one coming around to
score throw gets away from haas at the
plate
it's an extra 90 feet for ren heapho and
the angels are the first to score
tonight
david fletcher hits the hole on the
right side that scores wren
heapho two nothing angels the angels
lineup
is sitting on the heater here but his
secondary pitches are the ones gonna set
up the fastball that's a good idea to
use it
see that's it right there wow he slipped
a 95 mile an hour heater right past
upton who was not looking fastball
3-2 pitch it looked like grossman got
caught in between there
he wasn't sure if he was going gonna
throw it in the dirt that's why that's
what he got you just look for the ball
up
if it's up bam you go for it
got him to chase through him a slider
there in a two strike count
four punch outs for shohei otani through
three
hey mike what's it been like having fans
back in the ballpark is it
is it just like you know the way it's
supposed to be or was it weird at first
no it's not supposed to be obviously no
fans
it was tough i mean we feed off at
players feed off especially later in
later uh later in the summer you're
feeding off the energy from the crowd
and obviously full capacity tonight it's
uh
it's pretty electric tonight let's get
some offense going well he's got a
couple more years left on his massive
contract
and he's 94 hits shot oh man that got
him in the helmet
he just got away from ohtani that's
always scary that
going up up and in into the batters head
and
shoulder and neck area those are scary
scary moments for
batters yeah you're right it got him in
the arm
mercifully herrera is okay
eric with the bouncer up over the middle
it's going to turn into an inning ending
double play the angels were in the
perfect
spot first and second nobody out and
detroit is
turned away in the fourth i'll tell you
what guys now this watching with this
angle
manny's really starting to settle down
95 with his basketball he's relaxed now
back to manning who makes a very
athletic play
and gets through the side despite the
two out single
so here's daz cameron now with one out
and one on
another bouncer another chance for two
fletcher gets one
in the second five play by david
fletcher
filling in for jose glacier shortstop
one out here in the fifth he'll face
justin upton for a third time
struck him out for a second time on a
lively 95 mile an hour heater and he's
feeling it now
and he loses ohtani for the second time
this is what happened when shohei
got to first base with miguel cabrera
that's that's miguel
cabrera all the time doesn't matter who
it is
that's him all day there he goes again
and ward is locked up on a 95 mile an
hour heater
all that for nothing one gun for
jonathan scope who struck out twice in
the game tonight 2-1
oh man well headed to left field upton
can only
watch and that one is gone a hangar that
jonathan scope
crushes to make it a one-run game
jonathan has been on the tear
late and that's what he does with
mistakes
and there's one that's bounced to the
right side ohtani picks it up
[Applause]
dance moves i'm telling you just cannot
take your eyes off this guy
everything he does is is better
and more fun to watch than with anybody
else in the league
it's a slider and it's five strikeouts
for rotani
that was just a great opportunity great
time to steal got this picture
[Applause]
this is awkward this is awkward
walsh is involved now
[Laughter]
[Applause]
jose iglesias is the pitch hitter a
non-starter getting a scheduled day off
his
feet he picks on the first pitch and
drives it into left field
gren scores fletcher is held at third
and it's three to one angels
taylor ward with the bases loaded for
three tonight so far
ward swings and sends a drive to left
field that one's got a chance
taylor ward's first career hit with the
bases loaded
is a grand slam that has blown this one
wide open
into right field down in front of ward
it's going to score
one as grossman crosses the plate a 7-3
angels lead you love to see a pitcher
trying to get you out in the on the
plate
oh absolutely and this right here this
number's going to get another
iglesias just able to get there for the
out but yes an additional run does score
as
scope crosses the plate a two run game
now with two out in the ninth
one to the shifted second baseman
fletcher's throw
is able to retire the side and finish
business tonight wow